Hi I'm Jeff Scudder and I work
with the Google Spreadsheets
Data API. You might already be
familiar with Google
Spreadsheets. An online
spreadsheets application that
allows for real-time
collaboration.
It's part of our Google Docs
suite. The spreadsheets API
allows you to programmatically
access and modify your
spreadsheet data in your
language of choice.
Google provides client
libraries in a variety of
languages, which simplify
working with the
spreadsheets API.
And I've recently made an
addition to the Python library
that makes it easier to use
spreadsheets as a simple
text database.
One of the great things about
using Google Spreadsheets as a
simple database is that you
can see and modify all of
your data from a nice
user interface.
and your data is available on
any machine as long as you're
connected to the internet you
can interact with the data in
your Google Documents.
Let's get started.
First off, the Python client
library is open source and
available at
code.google.com/p/gdata-python-client
This module is called "text db"
and it lives within the gdata
spreadsheet package of the
gdata client library.
The spreadsheet module allows
you to use all of the features
in the spreadsheet's API and
the new "text db" module is
built on top of it.
The "text db" module
streamlines a specific
use case and makes
using the spreadsheets API feel
like using a simple database.
There's much more that you can
do with the spreadsheet's API
like use formulas, pulling
data from other sources, and
update a large number of
cells at once.
But I decided to make this
module about ease of use.
Let's take a look a look at a
sample of how to use the
text "db module."
We'll begin by importing the
module which has classes that
make it easy to use Google
Spreadsheets like a simple
database in the cloud.
Next, I'll import a demo
module which enters my email
address for me so that it's not
broadcast to the world thanks
to this video.
Now we can create a new Google
Spreadsheet using our client.
It's easy. All you need to
provide is a name.
The database object represents
our new Google Spreadsheet and
we're ready to create a table.
But first, let's take a look at
this document in Google Docs.
Okay, let's say that we have a
table of knights and we want
to ask their name,
quest, and favorite color.
Our spreadsheet now has a new
worksheet and we're ready
to add some information.
Let me open that now.
Now we'll see a new row appear
in our spreadsheet.
We can also add information
through the spreadsheet's
user interface.
If we're working with existing
data we may need to start by
finding the spreadsheet, which
you can do by looking up the
name of the spreadsheet or the
unique spreadsheet key id.
Since you can have multiple
spreadsheets with the same
name, the "getdatabases" method
returns a list.
You can retrieve rows of data
in several ways.
You can look up a single row,
or request a range of rows
using "getrecords."
Since we only have three rows
of data, rows contains
three items.
You can also search for rows
which match certain
requirements using spreadsheet
structured query language.
Structured queries can contain
and or less than greater than
exact matches and not equals.
We had two knights with the
favorite color of blue.
So, as you can see we have
two matches.
Once we have our rows, we can
make changes to the data in
our Google Spreadsheet.
One of the potential challenges
in storing your data in the
cloud is that read and write
operations may be slow because
they're transferring data over
slow and potentially flakey
network connections. To avoid
this problem in the "text db"
library, changes to local
objects are only sent to the
server when you call the push
method. In our example earlier,
we forgot to enter
Galahad's quest.
Let's do that now.
Let's take a look at the
content in our record.
Now we're going to send this
change to the server and we
should see the quest in our
spreadsheet update.
I also see that we
got Galahad's favorite
color wrong.
To show retrieving updates
which have happened outside
of the local copy of the data
we'll make a change
in the spreadsheet.
Our local copy doesn't have
the change yet but after we
pull the data you can see the
content has been updated.
I've just walked you through
a simple example of using the
"text db" module to use Google
Spreadsheets as if it were a
database in the cloud.
This is just one of the ways
that you can use the
spreadsheets API.
And although this example is
in Python, a similar library
could be built in almost
any language.
All of the code that I've used
in this sample is open source
so you're free to copy it and
modify it as you like.
If you think of some other
interesting things that you'd
like to do using the
spreadsheet's API, we would
love to hear about it.
Please visit us in the Google
Docs Data API Group.
You can also check out the
documentation for the API on
code.google.com